toi il est bienvenus dans votre journal
de l'Afrique à la ligne de l'actualité
sur le continent des unités de l'armée
congolaise mise en cause par Human Right
Swatch d'après l'ONG des Millis seraient
combattus aux côtés d'officier au même
titre que les Forces démocratiques de
libération du Rwanda elle aussi appelée
en renfort
près de 5000 personnes en manifesté ce
mardi à Zarzis ont Tunisie
immobilisation pour interpeller les
autorités les contraindre intensifier
les recherches des corps de leurs
proches disparus en mer il y a plus d'un
mois
et puis plus léger nous irons Sénégal
sadiovanais fait la fierté de son pays
l'attaquant du Bayern Munich est arrivé
deuxième au classement du Ballon d'Or
hier
la République démocratique du Congo
selon une note publiée ce mardi par
Human Rights des groupes armées ont été
appelés en renfort par des officiers ces
militaires aux mères et même fournis des
munitions assainies et en échange ces
hommes auraient pris part à la lutte
contre la rébellion du M23 les
précisions d'Aurélie bazarra kimbangoula
elle est à Kinshasa pour France 24
selon Human what what des éléments de
l'armée congolaise ont collaboré avec
une coalition de groupes armées
entremets et août 2022 dans la province
du Nord qui vous des unités des FRD
aurait donc cherché du renfort armé dans
l'est du pays pour combattre le M23 un
groupe armé en 2013 mais qui a fait son
retour en novembre dernier l'ONG accuse
certains officiers congolais d'avoir
apporté dans certains cas un soutien
direct au groupe armés elle cite par
exemple le cas de militaires du régiment
de Togo longa qui aurait fourni des
dizaines de caisses de munitions au FDLR
un groupe armée rwandais dont certains
membres ont participé au génocide au
Rwanda selon Kigali pour l'ONG avec ce
soutien l'armée congolais se rend
complice des actions commises par
certaines milices plusieurs d'entre
elles sont accusées de meurtres de
violences sexuelles ou encore de vol
l'ONG appelle les autorités congolaises
à mettre fin à ce soutien et à
poursuivre les officiers responsables
l'armée elle se refuse à tout
commentaire officiel pour le moment ces
accusations de graves interviennent
alors que Félix cheeseccady ne cesse de
dénoncer le soutien armé de Kigali à la
rébellion du M23 le chef de l'État
congolais tente de convaincre la
communauté internationale de prendre des
sanctions contre le Rwanda
après l'explosion d'un engin thessalite
hier en quatrième casque bleu a succombé
à ses blessures aujourd'hui s'il salue
la détermination de ces hommes sur le
terrain le chef de la mission de l'ONU
au Mali appelle à plus de moyens il
décrit une situation sécuritaire et
humanitaire plus que difficile à Shrek
vertu en résume le dernier rapport
présenté devant le Conseil de sécurité
un rapport point d'étape sur le Mali
quelques mois après le renouvellement du
mandat de la minusma la mission des
Nations unies dans le pays sur le plan
sécuritaire d'abord la situation est
toujours préoccupante le document relève
un pic d'activité des groupes
terroristes et une extension à l'ouest
et au sud de la zone géographique où ils
opèrent la fin cet été du retrait de la
force française barkhane a clairement
fragilisé la minusma le secrétaire
général de l'ONU demande donc une hausse
du nombre de casques bleus dont 4 ont
encore perdu la ville lundi à
thessalites dans la région de Kidal
ça n'est que le dernier incident en date
il témoigne de l'environnement difficile
dans lequel évolue la force de maintien
de la paix de l'ONU le rapport pointe
aussi du doigt de nouvelles violations
présumées de droits de l'homme
principalement le fait des groupes
djihadistes mais aussi de l'armée
malienne 32 enquêtes onusiennes sont en
cours la présentation de ce rapport à
l'ONU pourrait aussi être l'occasion
pour Bamako de préciser ses accusations
contre la France depuis le mois d'août
le Mali promet de présenter des preuves
d'un soutien de Paris à des groupes
terroristes sahéliens par ailleurs le
sort des 46 soldats ivoiriens toujours
détenus à Bamako pourrait être évoqué
arrêtez le 10 juillet à l'heure arrivée
à l'aéroport ils ont été accusés d'être
des mercenaires venus attenter à la
sûreté de l'État l'ONU dément et affirme
qu'il devait participer à la sécurité du
contingent allemand des casques bleus au
Mali
pour des dizaines de familles de Zarzis
en Tunisie depuis la disparition en mer
de leurs proches il y a un peu plus d'un
mois ils n'ont toujours pas récupéré les
corps ils se sont alors mobilisés ce
mardi objectif contraindre les autorités
intensifiées les recherches Caroline
Lamboley nous en dit plus
[Musique]
déclinant des slogans du printemps arabe
de 2011 des milliers de Tunisiens ont
battu le pavé mardi à Zarzis ville
toujours sous le choc après le naufrage
meurtrier du mois dernier
[Musique]
nous voulons connaître la vérité c'est
un crime d'État qui a été perpétré
contre les habitants de Zarzis avec
l'enterrement des corps sans
identification ni d'analyses ADN
de plus petites manifestations avaient
déjà eu lieu mais mardi commerçant et
fonctionnaires ont aussi répondu à un
appel à la grève générale lancé par
lugette été le principal syndicat du
pays
les naufrages d'embarcation de fortune
sont fréquents au large de la Tunisie
mais le drame du mois dernier les a
particulièrement touchés toutes les
personnes à bord étaient originaires de
Zarzis
les autorités ont inhumé par erreur 4
migrants tunisiens dans un cimetière
réservé habituellement aux migrants
étrangers les corps ont depuis été
exhumés lundi le président Kais a appelé
à approfondir davantage l'enquête alors
que plusieurs personnes sont toujours
portées disparues les manifestants ont
aussi appelé mardi les autorités à
intensifier leurs recherches
aucune voix dissonante ne semble être
tolérée à Conakry c'est le bal des a été
interpellé ce lundi il est un proche de
l'opposant Cellou da Landi à l'eau sont
partis l'Union des Forces Démocratiques
de Guinée parlent dans les vent et exige
sa libération immédiate je propose
d'écouter son avocat il répondait aux
questions de
nouvelles
il a une adresse il a une domicile fixe
et n'est pas un homme qui vit dans la
clandestinité il vit au grand jour comme
Étienne se reproduit par exemple comme
phoniquement gay par exemple
pour l'amener le maître face à dans une
enquête pour l'amener dans une enquête
une simple convocation suffit c'est pas
une Aristide c'est un kidnapping et
quand on est dans un kidnapping on n'a
pas besoin de procédure donc nous en
tant qu'avocat nous continuerons à nous
battre pour le respect des libertés
les perspectives économiques en
certaines pour le continent voilà les
conclusions du dernier rapport du Fond
Monétaire International les chiffres ne
sont effectivement pas rassurants à la
croissance ralentit 3,6% cette année
c'est un point de moins qu'en 2020 les
autres indicateurs ne sont pas plus
rassurant recevait un petit peu plus tôt
Luc héros il est le chef de la division
charge des études régionales
nous venons en effet de publier le
rapport sur les perspectives économiques
de l'Afrique subsaharienne et le titre
sur la corde raide reflète la situation
de l'Afrique subsaharienne aujourd'hui
avec des risques très importants à une
situation difficile la croissance comme
vous l'avez dit à ralentinettement cette
année sous l'effet de trois chocs
mondiaux qui ont frappé l'Afrique de
plein de fouet d'abord je dirais le
ralentissement économique dans les pays
avancés et la Chine le deuxième choc
c'est un resserrement des conditions
financières internationales très fort dû
à l'inflation mondiale le troisième
c'est
un renchérissement très fort des prix
des produits de base et des produits
alimentaires et tous ces chocs affectent
l'Afrique subsaharienne en réduisant ces
débouchés d'exportation en renchérissant
ces importations et en rendant
l’endettement beaucoup plus difficile et
plus cher ce qui veut dire tous les pays
ne sont je vous en prie poursuivez
tous les pays ne sont pas affectés de la
même manière mais dans l'ensemble on a
quand même une révision des perspectives
de croissance très fortes à la baisse
pour la plupart des pays c'est pour ça
qu'on a ce type de sur l'accord de rêve
est-ce qu'il y a donc clairement un
risque de récession
alors non pas vraiment de récession on a
quand même une croissance encore à 3 et
demi pour cent donc c'est une croissance
relativement qui est faible par rapport
au potentiel de croissance de l'Afrique
mais ce n'est pas une récession
le descriptif que vous venez de faire
est-ce qu'on peut aussi le lier aux
crises qui sont enchaînés succéder crise
sanitaire énergétique sécuritaire et on
vient de d'établir ensemble les faits
vous aviez vous l'avez précisé on perd
un peu plus d'un pour cent par rapport à
la croissance l'an dernier mais ce qu'on
peut simplement lier cette situation
actuelle qui concerne donc proprement le
continent africain c'est succession de
crise où est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
paramètres
moi je pense que la décélération de la
croissance en Afrique aujourd'hui bien
sûr il y a des paramètres domestiques et
des chocs comme des chocs sécuritaires
dans le Sahel mais globalement la
décélération est principalement liée je
dirais à des chocs externes les trois
chocs dont j'ai parlé et ces chocs sont
en grande partie liés à la guerre en
Ukraine
est-ce qu'il y a aussi un risque
désormais de débordement de mouvements
sociaux par ricochet d'instabilité
politique et pour parler clairement
est-ce qu'on peut se diriger vers des
émeutes de la fin
alors en effet il y a l'un des sujets
principaux aujourd'hui dans l'Afrique
survienne à des défis principaux c'est
l'insécurité alimentaire aujourd'hui on
a 123 millions de personnes en Afrique
subsaharienne soit plus d'une personne
sur 10 qui sont en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire aiguë donc
c'est la situation est particulièrement
préoccupante notamment dans la corde de
l'Afrique ou comme vous le savez
peut-être qu'il y a une sécheresse très
importante historique qui frappe cette
cette région de l'Afrique donc la
combinaison de cette hausse des produits
alimentaires et de la baisse des revenus
qui était déjà liés à la crise de la
covid évidemment créer des tensions
sociales très fortes dans tous les pays
et on a observé dans nombreux pays des
formes et contentement sociaux liés à
cette cette hausse des prix et cette
baisse des revenus et cet effet ciseaux
entre hausse des prix et baisse des
revenus il va donc falloir accompagner
les populations vulnérables à porter
peut-être une sorte de compensation
est-ce que cela c'est possible surtout
lorsqu'on a aussi en tête un problème de
gouvernance dans certains états
alors je dirais que c'est non seulement
possible mais c'est nécessaire c'est à
dire que le au FMI nous aidons les pays
à mettre en place des mesures de soutien
aux populations les plus vulnérables
alors le problème c'est que souvent en
effet les marges de manœuvre
budgétaires sont assez limités donc on
essaie de faire en sorte que c'est ces
mesures soient le plus ciblées possible
pour qu'elles aillent vraiment aux
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin donc
c'est un des priorités je dirais de
notre action dans la région
une actualité plus légère et plus
heureuse Sadio Mané célébrée au Sénégal
chez lui l'attaquant du Bayern Munich et
éclaté deuxième au Ballon d'Or c'est la
deuxième fois qu'un joueur africain
monte sur le podium à Sadio Mane a par
ailleurs reçu le Prix Socrate pour son
engagement social et Liman Dao a
recueilli quelques réactions à Dakar
la deuxième place historique de Sadio
Mané au Ballon d'Or vient consacré une
année exceptionnelle du numéro 10 de
l'équipe nationale du Sénégal a de
football vainqueur des deux Coupes
nationales en Angleterre mais également
à suivi champion d'Angleterre et
d'Europe vainqueur de la Coupe d'Afrique
des nations et élu meilleur joueur
africain de l'année ce sont au-delà de
ces performances sur le terrain les
performances ou les
œuvres en dehors du terrain qui ont été
récompensés par France Football avec le
trophée socratech récompensa toutes les
œuvres faites par Sadio Mane en dehors
du terrain la construction de l'hôpital
de lycée des œuvres sociales dans son
village à bambali ce mardi dans les rues
de Dakar les Sénégalais que nous avons
rencontrés se disent très fier du niant
le guerrier en langue socie une langue
locale l'autre sur l'eau de Sadio Mane
c'est vraiment un exemple pour la
jeunesse sénégalaise africaine de façon
générale
il faut dire que on
faut pas oublier d'où on vient
franchement il est de cette quelqu'un de
grand cœur quoi vraiment et raison pour
laquelle tout le peuple sénégalais lui
ont souhaité ce prix
beaucoup pour lui j'espère qu'il va
continuer à remporter d'autres trophées
c'est une grande fierté
après ces distinctions Sadio Mané à
certainement en tête la plus haute
marche du podium au Ballon d'Or pour
cela il faudrait réaliser une très bonne
Coupe du monde le Mondial de football
qui démarre dans exactement un mois et
dans le Sénégal fait partie des nations
africaines les plus attendues ainsi
s'achève votre journal de l'Afrique
merci de votre fidélité à nos chaînes
[Musique]